Some of the most important discoveries
in Elden Ring's early-game..are
surprisingly easy to miss.
For example, one of the most valuable
consumables in Elden Ring is the Flask of
Wondrous Physick, which has its single charge
replenished every time you rest at a grace
checkpoint. That alone should easily earn
it an esteemed place on your quick-select
bar, as it's the sort of thing you should
try to consume for every major encounter.
You can find your flask at the Third Church
of Marika, located to the east... here.
But what does it do? Well..that's up to you.
By mixing in different crystal tear combinations
at a grace checkpoint, you can alter its effects.
For example, here, my crimsonburst tear heals me
over time, and my opaline bubbletear gives me a
shield that protects me from the next attack
I'll be hit by. You can get both of these
tears from the field boss fought here.
Another essential item is the Whetstone Knife,
which allows you to apply ashes of war to your
armaments. You can find a Whetstone Knife here,
in a cellar underneath the Gateside Ruins. With
this, your weapons can get new skills..and new
scaling options to better suit your build.
If you want to quickly get a lot of ashes of war,
make sure to visit Bernahl during the
day here, at the Warmaster's Shack.
And if you find yourself wielding two weapons,
then you might want to duplicate an ash of war
for both of them. To do this, you'll need to trade
Lost Ashes of War at the Blacksmith.
You're going to want to talk to the blacksmith
pretty early, since the smithing table at the
Church of Elleh can only get your weapons to +3,
and the blacksmith can take them well beyond that.
To talk to him though, first, we'll have to
be invited to the roundtable hold. It's hard
to know exactly what triggers Melina to invite
you... I know you definitely get taken there if
you defeat Margitt at Stormveil Castle ... but
failing that, you will eventually get invited
simply after exploring the world for a while.
Defeating Margitt is also important because he
gives you your first Talisman Pouch. With each
pouch you collect, you gain another talisman slot.
Talismans are like rings from previous
games, offering powerful and diverse benefits
to your character.
Just like talismans, your spell memorisation slots
are now also tied to key items. So, If you want
to memorise more than two spells at a time, then
you'll need to seek out Memory Stones. Your first
Memory Stone can be found at Iridys Rise, where
you'll have to solve a simple puzzle in order
to gain access, and open the chest within.
Put this in your new memory slot: the world
is more dangerous at night. In addition to
night-enemies, tons of night-bosses also seem to
spawn. So, if you're looking for more night bosses
you think you might have missed in the early-game,
head here ..... here....here.... and here.
To offset this apparent rise in
world difficulty, in my experience,
your rune acquisition at night is also boosted.
This is thanks to three new mechanics.
The first, is this. When the Erdtree graces you
with the golden rain of its leaves, you've just
chanced upon a rare weather effect that buffs your
character. What does it do? Well..I'm not sure
exactly. The icon here is that of a four-fingered
fowl foot, which has items that increase item
discovery and rune aquisition. Now..the guide says
that the fowl foot increases rune acquisition by
5%..so I guess that's likely to be correct,
though my testing revealed nothing of the sort.
The only other option is that it boosts item
acquisition. Whatever the case, it's probably
a good idea to farm some enemies while this
buff is active, based on the icon, at least.
The second thing to look out for are enemies with
golden eyes. In my experience, these enemies drop
4x the amount of runes when killed. So if you
see an enemy with golden eyes..kill them. I love
this mechanic. It encourages you to take up some
fights that you might usually have ran past.
Last, but not least - be on the lookout
for glowing white skulls upon the ground.
Once broken apart, these will give you golden
rune consumables. They spawn in random locations,
and can be easily looted by trampling them with
torrent and spamming the loot button.
Some folks will want to spend these
runes on becoming more powerful,
but that's lame. Instead, you should spend
them on looking gorgeous, and getting that
Elden Bling. (use new trailer footage)
What I'm doing here is called Armour Alteration,
where elements of some sets of armour can be
changed for a small price. For example, a cloak
can be added to the commoner set, and prophets
can be freed from their neckpiece. Of course,
every armour piece is different, so check it
out for 500 runes, and see what changes.
To unlock armour alteration, you'll have
to defeat the boss of the Demi-human
Cave [CHECK] in southwestern Limgrave.
When you're victorious, you'll receive
the tailoring kit, and a sewing needle.
The tailoring kit unlocks armour alteration,
but the sewing needle is actually a part
of Boc's questline. Boc's questline can be
started in a grove of trees located here ...
and I suspect his questline might lead towards
more armour alteration.
When I started this build,
I wanted to be a glorious faithful valkyrie kind
of character. Then I found a black crossbow,
a spell that casts darkness, and an evil looking
flail. These things were way too edgy 5 me,
but luckily, in Elden Ring, you can
change your character's appearance to
better suit your build! So that's what I did.
It's easy to miss, but in Fia's room at Roundtable
Hold, go up to this mirror. Here, you'll be
able to return to the character creation screen,
and change everything except your
starting stats and keepsake.
Make sure you frequently return to Roundtable
hold to see if anything's changed, or if any
new NPC's have dropped by. Roderika should be
one of the first new appearances - and while
you can first talk to her here, at the Stormhill
shack..that doesn't seem absolutely necessary
for her questline. Progress, and she should
eventually show up at Roundtable hold,
whether you've talked to her before or not.
By talking to her, then the blacksmith,
then her again, you can trigger a progression
in her questline. After reloading the area,
she will have found her purpose - as a spirit
tuner, someone who you should return to frequently
to upgrade the strength of your favourite
phantoms. Of course, if you haven't already,
you can get the spirit summon bell from Renna,
when you return to the Church of Elleh.
The resource used for upgrading
your spirits is called Glovewort.
Regular spirits require Grave Glovewort, and
special spirits require Ghost Glovewort. Glovewort
is found all throughout catacomb dungeons, and
unlike other resources, it doesn't appear to
respawn after resting at a grace checkpoint, so
be sure to loot these dungeons thoroughly.
Number 9 is one of my favourite new things they've
added to the game, bar none. Paintings. After you
interact with one, the puzzle has begun. Your
job now is to go and find that place depicted
in the painting...in the actual world.
This painting, for example, asked me to
find these gravestones. I remembered seeing
them a while ago, so I tracked them down,
and was rewarded by the painter. I got a scarab
headpiece that increases my damage taken, but
increases the damage my spells do.
The second painting was far trickier. It
was this one, in Stormveil Castle. I'm not going
to tell you where it depicts - but I will give you
an important clue for all your paintings going
forward - remember: you don't have to find the
place depicted in the painting. You have to
find the location it was painted FROM.
If you ever need to review the paintings you're
tracking, you can find them in your inventory menu
here, at the top of the screen.
A new feature in Elden Ring are Group Passwords.
Unlike Multiplayer Passwords, which restrict
you to ONLY interact with players using the same
password - Group Passwords simply let you visually
distinguish who is using the same password as you,
and who isn't. For example, this sign on
the left is using the same group password,
and the sign on the right..isn't. The same
goes for phantoms, messages, and bloodstains,
and I think it will be cool to see others from
our community while you're playing the game.
So..I want to make a community group called
"Secret Seekers". Our community password will be
"SEEKERS", all capitalised like that. As
a secret seeker, it's your job to drop
your gold summon sign, or a message, and guide
others to a secret..whether that's a dungeon,
or a hidden path nearby. If you're happy with
a message, then upvote it! And if you have a
good co-op session that leads to finding
a new secret, then consider dropping a
reward for your fellow seeker! Remember, our
community password is "SEEKERS".
Oh..and speaking of special codes - if you go
to audible dot com slash vaatividya or text
vaatividya to five hundred five hundred, then
you can claim your free 30-day Audible trial,
and get full access to thousands and
thousands of all-you-can-listen audiobooks,
original entertainment, and podcasts included
in the Plus Catalog. Additionally, you'll get
credit for one full audiobook..completely free
- and this month, I'm recommending you download
the audiobook for the Lord of the Rings.
One ring to rule them, all.
One ring, to find them. One ring, to bring
them all, and in the darkness, bind them.
It just seems so fitting to recommend this story
now, on the eve of Elden Ring's release. Two
stories about rings of power, set in enormous
worlds that draw you into their fantasy.
Maybe have a listen while you do grindy
stuff in-game, like foraging for materials,
farming runes, or grinding for enemy
item drops. That's how I tend to use
Audible - It's pretty fantastic to be inspired
and productive, at the same time. So remember,
go to audible dot com slash vaatividya or text
vaatividya to five hundred five hundred, and
get your free trial started.”
So thank you to Audible for sponsoring
this video...and thank you, for
watching.